hello I am Greg Tolkien and I'm Laura
Marano
so Laura I think it's important that
people understand how we met and how we
know each other we did this new movie
together a Cinderella story a Christmas
wish hi ho ho ho holiday ground we work
together but now we're really getting to
know each other in this moment in this
interview I don't even know what your
middle name is I know that you have a
middle name
number one question that wasn't even a
question but I that was something I was
curious I know I've got some questions
for you and I believe you've got some
questions for you yes I do when you
found out that I was involved let's be
real as if the cameras aren't here did
you think to yourself how do I get out
of this contract yeah I was just like ah
I'm not Greg not Gregg Sulkin who
doesn't have a middle name I was so
happy you during this filming I think I
felt the same too in the sense that
obviously you never know what you're
gonna sign of sort of like sign up for
and I remember knowing that you were the
number one on the movie I sort of like
put me at ease
normally the Cinderella story yes the
originated with Hilary Duff were you a
fan of the movie oh my goodness gracious
is that even a question yes a hundred
times over a Cinderella story starring
Hilary Duff was a very iconic movie she
said the best line of all time when
she's like confronting Chad Michael
Murray's character waiting for you
waiting for you is like waiting for rain
in this drought waiting for rain in the
strapped and that ladies and gentlemen
is why Laura Marano has cost in this
version of a Cinderella story where's
the car you have one job you're dragging
the bags uses a little spaghetti our
butt is its tail stone the big Winter
Garden - she infinities in class
I need to get him in my blog take this
my way get out of my way I play cat
Dekker and I pay Dominic Wintergarden
who originally was meant to be English I
think Laura and I spoke about Dominic
sort of with the name Winter Garden we
assumed that he was gonna be English
drivers like do you think it's okay if
I'm like having English accent and
that's I'm like Oh a hundred percent the
previous Cinderella had an English actor
and English accent and so I think they
chose chose American for me which was
fun
your American accent is spot-on um if I
were playing someone who's English that
would be not good cuz I speak like this
yeah thank God we stop with the America
i order the decaf I am so sorry some
clumsy girl threw her Starbucks
all over the gorgeous Dominic winter
garden okay er you know cats are
Cinderella in this movie I just remember
when we were doing the big sort of like
ending of the movie I just remember
obviously there was playback but you
were actually singing on top of your
playback and I just I just feel like I
can commend you for it because one my
vocal chops definitely wouldn't last
that long and it's just to sing in front
of so many people is is a it's a big
thing it's a big feat I had to keep
drinking water because I try to stay
hydrated keep drinking water keep
turning tea which resulted in you then
having to go to the restroom dress I've
ever worn in my entire life and so that
was quite awkward I felt like it was
like every 2530 minutes
it was a whole thing but the beard was
not fun yeah bid was an ideal yeah
definitely you know rock it though
I'd have to if I played center again I'd
ask probably for a different bid it has
to be a custom being made out of favor
obviously but yes you know something a
little bit more gentle on the skin
[Music]
it was actually really cool to do in
Vancouver because there's a bunch of
people that we knew Vancouver's just
like the area that everyone film oh yeah
we went to the restaurant where we view
: where you couldn't see the dark
restaurant
I forgot I actually block that out
because it was so there like should I
wrap coal out so the show Riverdale
shoots in in Vancouver and so Laura and
I have friends with a couple of the cast
members and so we went out to dinner one
night there was this restaurant that has
it's completely pitch black I didn't
think of the fact that going to a dark
restaurant it's probably not the first
sort of like group meet hangout location
all of us like we're connecting and
bonding over the anxiety that we felt
like it was it was pretty crazy because
you can't see anyone you can't see your
food we were eating dinner or having
loft and then suddenly the person
sitting in front of me Cole I'm not
proud of this but I may have kind of um
instigated him a little bit he was like
should I I have my camera should I take
a photo with flash right before his film
camera and I'm like yeah do it do it I
don't know what came over me I it was
great because he did it first off if
you've sat in the dark for 30 minutes
and suddenly the brightest flash comes
in front of your eyes you literally like
you don't know what like you know you
see stars you go dizzy it's like a weird
very weird sensation the whole
restaurant was like the whole Buddhist
arc but then we joined in on the room
yeah yeah we did on the roof because we
thought well we don't want to be the
table that's not booing and that sound
sort of silent over there
is the table that did it I think that
was one of the highlights of the trip
for sure who is your favorite Murano
sister near Vanessa both of you could
change the world I do believe that I
think both of you are like very strong
independent powerful women you both come
from like very you know a very
intelligent family and so you're both
you
I love seeing how uncomfortable you are
with the squad Vanessa specifically yeah
I've gone around in a circle now from
Italy I think Vanessa is very
opinionated and very strong and where I
believe that when she wants something
and when she has something to say he
should be a lawyer she's not shy yet to
her voice her opinion she's a smart
cookie she's so smart it's actually yes
I think I feel I see I can't win with it
I can't wait I can't win we're just
gonna say we love both of burano sisters
and I support them fully always until I
pass and go to heaven hopefully and yeah
I'm on Team Iran oh you're sweating yeah
because I was like oh I was gonna say
like how I see I'm gonna put myself in
again no both equally love love love
love so real talk right now
real talk you and your girlfriend
Michelle are a fairytale couple you
would have probably the most beautiful
children ever in the entire world I
always said if I were to have a child
with me sure I definitely want the child
hopefully to take Michelle's looks
because she is absolutely stunning my
favorite thing aside from Michelle's
exterior beauty truly is like how
kind-hearted she is you're making
everyone just like fall in love with you
guys even more right now I mean it's hot
it's not me because she is she's a very
special soul a rare soul she's pretty
awesome yeah it's just so very
warm-hearted and you know such a kind
and sensitive heart so I think aside
from the exterior you know beauty I
think she's she's you know she's done
okay so your girlfriend is Cassie from
The Bachelor sister yes are you closer
Colton yes
give us the deep what what's the double
date like I mean do you guys ride in
helicopters do you guys have champagne
do you what's the situation look
obviously have what - no Cassie because
of you know Michelle I'm you know I knew
Cassie before she went on the show
and she's still the same girl she's
still a lovely girl they're both
Michelle and cassia both from their
family Matt and Amy are amazing and so
today you're scoring like the only
points right now like it's true you know
like legit they're like a very lovely
like family that live by the beach
and uh and then you know colt is just
sort of like fitted in beautifully so I
remember you saying pretty casually you
were like yeah my girlfriend's sisters
on The Bachelor and cut to like a week
later and I see on Twitter it's all
about Kathy obviously I come from a very
traditional background in the sense of
like in the entertainment industry I've
always sort of done TV and film and
reality is something that I've never
done and so to see the fan base and to
see the power of reality I hope I
personally don't watch reality I still
haven't finished that bachelor season
well ya know I was sort of a paranoid
some stuff happened I don't really know
but now obviously I know what if there
was like she he jumped over a fence it's
a hole he's a strong boy and so to see
everyone loves the show everybody in
society loves you can't believe you and
finish watching yeah they're yummy which
is you know to each their own
Colton Colton
he just jumped the fence perfect date
was like a mini Austin & Ally
reunion would you be down for a real
Austin & Ally reboot where do you think
Austin and Ally would be today
a hundred percent yes I had the best
time working on a Cinelli and I loved
the cast and crew so much so yes
yes yes I would prefer if we pull the
Lizzie McGuire Movie and filmed it in a
exotic place well maybe Rome you put
some basil oil or maybe Hawaii the
channel in the finale we see how their
lives and 15 years later but we don't
see the kind of in-between I feel like
we would see Austin ally actually going
on tour together it's kind of a bummer
we never got to see that it'd be nice to
see the drama and chaos that comes with
that I would be down for that
[Music]